today we're covering how to use 3gs
post-processing
good by the end of this tutorial you
will understand what post-processing is
not just like a bunch of code but
fundamentally how it works in big games
the 3gs apis for post processing and how
to actually code this up
so let's dive in right away on what
exactly post processing is
now you can skip this part jump right to
the code but you may pick up some things
you didn't know
okay so what's post-processing you can
probably guess from the name
it's some sort of processing that
happens after ie the post part
there's some parallels with other forms
of media for example in movies
these days you always have some form of
post-production
easy example here's a behind the scenes
on the avengers
and here you've got all the actors green
screens then you have various bits of
background and cgi that are composited
in
there maybe some passives for the
overall look and tone of the movie
playing with color and all that crap
another example
you can see from these shots here's some
of the behind the scenes work on mad max
fury road
and a lot of effort went into
transforming the scenes from what was
filmed into the final shot
here's a few quick examples never mind
the introduction of additional scenery
but there's been a bunch of work
including color grading to get that
final stylistic effect the movie has
but it's not just limited to slight
color changes and that kind of thing
here they actually took day shots and
those can be transformed into super
stylized night shots through post work
and you can do similar types of things
on your home computer bring up photoshop
or the poor man's photoshop [ __ ] which
is what i use
and let's just load up an image i'll
just pick something to get us started
and i'll reproduce some common easy post
effects right here in [ __ ]
so for example you might want to play
with the saturation of the scene
so i can just go here into the menu
here's the saturation menu
and by sliding this back and forth see i
can completely desaturate the entire
thing giving me a black and white scene
or i can pump it up giving me i don't
know let's call it stylized
let's pull up one of the mad max fury
road scenes so
here's that desert shot no idea what was
going on there but
maybe i can go re-watch it anyway i'll
just go screw with some of the
parameters so let's go fiddle with the
color temperature and just drop it the
way the hell down
not bad but now let's go into the color
balance and here i can play with the
overall color in the scene and i'll just
crank the blue a bit
finally let's head over to the levels
menu and this kind of lets me set the
color range of the image and i'll just
slide
this up a bit here the final shot kinda
looks night timey
not bad i mean i don't do this for a
living so this is the best you're
getting from me
but you're not just totally limited just
messing around with color your effect
can be multi-stage
like here's a random city shot i found
off google images
and we take this and i'll duplicate the
layer next i'll go into the levels
editor and we'll screw around a bit just
to mostly leave the lights and bright
objects in the scene
that way we're left with everything
bright and shiny next we can go into the
contrast and boost that
and this can have the effect of making
what we're going to bloom out really
colorful
or you could go the other way too
desaturate it or skip this step
altogether
up to you once we're done there we can
go here to the blur
filter and we'll apply a gaussian blur
over the layer
so what we're left with is this kind of
blurry unfocused image
now when we take that layer we can
additively blend it over the original
image and voila
you've got a basic bloom effect the
point is
post processing is pretty much like
taking your image and photoshopping it
so how do games do post processing it's
not that dissimilar
typically you'll see a setup like this
where you're done rendering your scene
and you've got something like this
here's your color buffer here's your
depth buffer and now you're going to
take these inputs and whatever others
you decide to pass in
and you'll likely apply it to a texture
as a quad and render it out with a
custom vertex or fragment shader or both
so for example you start with this game
scene and maybe you have this custom
fragment shader that contrasts the scene
so you take your input image apply this
chunk of shader code that does the
simple contrast
and out comes the contrasted image maybe
in the next stage you take that as an
input and now you want to grayscale
things
so you apply another custom shader here
that converts to grayscale
and out comes the grayscaled image so
overall
we've got this whole post-processing
pipeline here where you start with the
game's rendered
image and then you've got this series of
steps where some sort of image
manipulation occurs
and it's important to note although in
our specific examples
each step was just a simple operation
they don't have to be
each step may do a whole bunch of crap
just like we did with the bloomed image
now let's take a look at 3js's
post-processing docs
first up you've got this effect composer
and as it says right here in the docs
this class manages a chain of
post-processing passes to produce the
final visual result
you can think of the effect composer as
the pipeline from before
it's responsible for managing each of
these steps and producing the final
image
and the way that you would use the
effect composer is by instantiating what
are called
passes and adding those to the effect
composer instance using this add pass
function
and passes are essentially the steps in
the post-processing pipeline
they're the ones that do all the heavy
lifting of actual image manipulation
so let's dive into the code like always
i'm going to skip some basic steps and
just work with what's already been made
so i'll start by creating a new
directory let's call it 3gs
tutorial post processing and i'm going
to copy
everything from the basic 3d world
tutorial into there
most of this is just setup code to get
us going there's nothing to be gained by
rewriting this boilerplate after you've
already done it once
in the code here we need to import the
required files first
at the top of the file here i've just
added these two lines to
import both the effect composer and the
render pass which is enough to get us
started
now down here in the init code we need
to do some basic changes to start using
post-processing
first thing we need to do is actually
instantiate an effect composer
and that's just a quick one line of code
where we knew an instance of effect
composer
and pass it the webgl renderer instance
as a parameter
now we need to add the first pass to it
and this is why we imported render pass
render pass's job is to actually render
the scene same way we normally do when
we call
3gs.render and pass the scene in camera
we actually have to pass the scene and
camera as parameters so that it can do
just that
render the scene for us and save it to a
texture the next change we need to make
is down in the render call
instead of calling 3gs render we're
switching that to composer.render
load this up and you see well a basic
scene but
it's running through the effect composer
now instead of just being composited
directly onto the scene
so that's something it's not much but
it's something
back in the code we'll actually have to
do something so first thing we'll do is
go to the top
and import unreal bloom pass which is
one of the built-in passes that 3js
already offers and this pass does
something pretty similar to what we did
in our photoshop example earlier
down in the main code after the effect
composer has been instantiated
we just need to instantiate an instance
of the unreal bloom pass
and we'll set some of the parameters you
don't need to worry too much about them
they're mostly
self-explanatory but since there doesn't
seem to be any documentation on it
i get to make up a bunch of crap
resolution refers to the internal size
of the render target it uses to create
the bloom buffer
strength refers to the strength of the
bloom effect radius refers to the size
of the bloom
threshold controls how bright things
need to be before they bloom
so now that we've got a bloom pass in
let's load this up and voila
bunch of bloom on the screen kinda neat
it gives a very dreamy vibe to things
and you could imagine having a city
scene at night
neon lights and this could be really
cool there's a whole lot more built-in
passes
in fact there's a whole directory full
of them here you can scroll through and
check them out
and of course you can always go to the
3gs examples and see what many of them
look like
i'm going to add glitch pass now just to
show you that it can be done
so here i'll have to import it again at
the top pretty much the same thing as we
did with unreal bloom pass
with the name glitch path subbed subduen
then down in the effect composer
it's a simple matter of instantiating an
instance of a glitch pass
so we'll write the line out nude glitch
pass and luckily this one doesn't take
any parameters so all we have to do is
create it
and add it and once that's done you can
load it and if you wait a second
you'll see it go off alright cool so we
have a couple passes
i'm going to mention another one that's
super accessible for beginners
you can define your own basic passes
using shader pass
as long as you supply a vertex and
fragment shader definition
there's a whole bunch of pre-built ones
already on github
you can scroll through and see the full
list i'll just add the luminosity shader
here just to show how it's done
so up at the top you import the shader
this time and it's in a slightly
different directory
but pretty much the same thing as
importing the passes
you also need to import this new shader
pass class and we'll use that for
creating a pass out of a shader
now down in the effect composer it's
just a tiny bit of extra work
you have to instantiate an instance of a
shader pass and we pass in the shader
and then of course add it to the effect
composer
loading that up should show off the new
pass so now you've got bloom
glitch and you luminosity passes running
the luminosity past being just a
grayscale thing where we visualize the
brightness of the scene
of course you can also just define your
own shader so here i've quickly crapped
out a quick one that does contrast
so the shader definition is pretty
simple i've got my uniforms in this case
i only need the previous render target
vertex shader does nothing except
transform the position and pass the uv
coordinates down
in the fragment shader we do a quick
texture lookup and then a contrast
operation this line here all it does is
you set a midpoint value
in my case i use 0.5 then you subtract
that
multiply by a contrast value and add
that 0.5 back in
the end result will be like pushing the
colors away from the midpoint
down here in the effect composer i'm
just going to remove the luminosity pass
and i'll swap it from my new shader
so that means i had to change the
parameter that's all
now when i load it up it's all super
contrasty
and i could of course go into the shader
and do a lot more but we're going to end
things here since this is just a
beginner tutorial
there's a lot more material to cover
with post effects like rolling your own
paths
but that's more involved maybe it needs
to down raise the image and filter it or
do some blurring all of which is
possible but way beyond a beginner level
hope this was interesting make sure to
like and subscribe
codes on github see you next time cheers